I think this is wonderful it's always
wonderful to be back at Stanford so many
familiar faces and I'm honored to be a
speaker here today uh
as a history of the seminar I was
involved when the seminar was started
initially uh with with Michael uh when
we we started this in double A
for those of you who joined us and for
those of you who might be joining us
online I am animesh Garg I am currently
at Nvidia uh and I split my time with
University of Toronto and I'll soon be
at Georgia Tech
I always like to start my talk with this
particular video that I've actually kept
constant for five plus years uh this
really is a reminder for me uh that this
is such an exciting problem to be
working on yet it is so hard that
progress actually is far slower than you
might believe it is uh so the problem
statement of a lot of my research is
very simple we want to build robots that
can help you in a general set of tasks
ideally something like what Rosie from
The Jetsons in 1960s could do
and and without that you want these
systems to do a variety of things from
cleaning cooking laundry and so on and
so forth and all of this really should
work in well not just the lab or demos
but homes or places where we really
wanted to work
so that brings me to what we really
study or algorithmically the core of our
current agenda is understanding both
reasoning and control for embodied
systems particularly in the purview of
robot manipulation and I believe this is
a two-stage process
first stage of this process is somehow
figuring out what is the task
uh how is the task specified it can be
specified in many ways you need to be
able to achieve the task in constrained
settings and then
we need yet another set of algorithms to
figure out how to generalize from that
specification uh to a broad range of
settings I use a chair as an example you
can you can give a demo of how to build
a chair but we really need to understand
the concept of building a chair
and today I I decided to do a talk as
Mark said slightly differently in the
sense instead of giving you a very
detailed overview of a few papers which
you can actually go and read by
yourselves many times I try to give you
an overview of my research trying to
give you the thread that connects them
and the questions that we can answer
which is often not visible in a single
Paper ever
so let's try to solve this problem right
you can try to solve these problems in
two ways one is what I would like to
call like more conventional uh robotics
manner where you can build these
structured pipelines where you can have
planning perception and control and
often these things are what I would call
one problem one solution there's nothing
wrong in it by the way it's just that uh
the nature of the solution
forces it to be structured the other end
of the spectrum can be let's say
motivated or inspired by Machine
learning techniques where you can just
add data and the hope is that the data
is effective enough in some amount of
large quantities that we will figure out
an end-to-end system that would achieve
these tasks
I would argue neither of these systems
are perfect uh on one end you need
experts this is limited applicability
there are trade-offs between performance
and flexibility
on the other aspect well the main
problem is computational sustainability
these days many data sets are so large
that we don't actually have access to
those models the data itself may not be
accessible to people and even then you
have out of distribution headers so it's
not clear this is the right approach
if you go back in the history of machine
learning before it was machine learning
or before it was deep learning to
psychology and before that to philosophy
this has been a consistent theme
across researchers over I would even say
centuries not even decades well you need
what they call an inductive bias to make
the inductive leap necessary for the
generalization we need I will describe
what what this means is
what they are basically saying is
there is no generalization without
structure now you might ask what is
structure well structure appears in many
ways
structure can be domain knowledge
inductive bias in the sense you have
models of particular kinds symmetries
priors models and then data itself is
also well it comes in different
varieties it's online offline simulated
real labeled self-supervised human or
automated
and if you look at let's say the success
of modern machine learning one could
argue that the three pillars of modern
machine learning are structured models
large data sets and large compute in
fact this formula has been fairly
successful pretty much sort of like it
keeps on going and we don't know when it
will start right now uh both in language
and in vision
you add data you train larger models
larger data sets seems to work
now the problem is robots appear to be
slightly different or ever so slightly
right robots break many of these
assumptions we don't have large data
sets the data sets are minuscule the
models are not yet structured
and compute is not required or at least
not as much we can very easily break a
lot of assumptions due to the fact that
this system is embodied
now all of these whether it's Vision
language or Robotics are incense
problems in study of intelligence
one would argue rather controversially
that uh
the problem of intelligence is built on
movement movement is the need that
results in intelligence in fact some
neuroscientists argue that when you
start movement
you eat your own brain so you don't need
to be intelligent there are actual
organisms which do that so then there is
an argument that movement is the primary
notion of why you need sensory cognitive
planning and all sorts of intelligence
uh that let's say people in vision and
language study about
in fact there is one more argument
intelligence is not this general purpose
thing that we think of it as there is no
notion that you can solve everything
with one set off
models every agent let's say humans
have a set of problems that we are built
for
and our hardware and learning mechanisms
are adapted to it it's just that that
set of problems is fairly broad which is
why it is interesting
so there is evidence from again
Neuroscience which says that humans are
hyper specialized even in Hardware human
adult brains have special regions for
identifying faces and identifying scenes
more than any generic perception and
this is something that has been
confirmed that this exists even in very
young babies this is not something that
you develop over time this is actually
hardwired
so you have structure structure for the
problems you are expected to solve
and the same happens in learned
specialization so this was a very
fascinating study
humans especially adults
can identify individuals often of Their
Own
species sometimes of their own race even
that is why there was this argument that
it's much harder for people to identify
individuals across races
but babies are very good at it to a
point that babies can identify
individuals of other species babies can
identify monkeys
but that that ability that exists in
about two-month-old babies goes away by
the by the time they're nine month old
which is remarkable because what it
tells us is
the ability to tell monkeys apart is not
a skill that you need very often so it
goes away soon the hardware supports it
it's just that the software does away
with it because the distribution of
tasks you need to do
does not require that
this brings us back to why we should be
studying structure
there is always going to be a set of
things you want your agents to do
and that set of things will dictate what
sort of structure you should have in
your system what sort of data or what
sort of implicit biases your data will
bring
okay
so broadly I study three things what
sort of structure representation should
we be thinking about in robotics how can
we discover this structure purely from
data and then because we are well indeed
roboticists how would we deploy this on
practical systems so that we can build
increasingly complex systems that are of
well practical use
for today's talk we will focus on one of
these things which is structure what
sort of structured inductive biases
should we think about for robotics
in particular we will try to give you
an overview of structure in three
particular questions
what sort of object level
representations should you look at how
will they come about
is there structure in the process of
decision making itself
and then finally can we do something by
learning from others in this process can
we do something better through the data
itself so let's get started
let's look at object oriented perception
and and let's get started with a problem
that I think many of you would be
familiar with something like assembly
putting things together
it is not necessarily assembling cars
and and complex things I am thinking
simple assembly like putting a cap on a
pin
right and then this sort of problems
appear so very often that it feels that
this there should be some sort of
geometric primitive in this like we
should have some underlying mechanism to
do this
this appears basically you can really
think of this problem as what we call
shape mating you are given two shapes
you should understand how they go
together if they go together
again this problem would appear in not
just assembly but like problems in well
broken buses broken sculptures fossils
maybe medicine broken bones
so we started by thinking like how can
we even study these problems so we
started with the shape data set
we tried to be fancy we took the data
set and we break it apart like we
literally break objects and then we also
make the problem Harder by making some
of these objects Hollow so that the
interface with the connect is not let's
say a full surface it's just edges and
ribs
so now essentially the problem is you
have these Point clouds inputs and you
want to figure out
how would they connect if they would
connect
so very simply this is a registration
problem you can start with two point
clouds you want to predict the rotation
and translation of these two point
clouds such that they can register
together into some shape it is important
to note because we are breaking objects
these are not parts
there is no semantic about any of these
parts you are essentially fracturing
things right
so if you do something that is very
common in computer vision which is
basically Point Cloud registration this
happens what this happens is basically
if you are registering two point clubs
that are similar let's say a bunny to a
bunny the usual standard bunny example
it works but if you are trying to
register things which are actually
mating together then the registration
surface is very small uh and that is why
these sort of model based methods result
in very high error
so we resort to a learning based method
where you now have to predict
essentially pose estimation loss
this is where structure comes in it
turns out that if you just force this
pose estimation loss you cannot actually
solve this problem you need to have a
prior of what the world of human shapes
look like
so we put in an adversary loss that if I
put a pen cap with a pen the thing
should look like a pin or thing should
look like an object in fact we also put
in one more prior well if I see half of
the object I should be able to impute
what the other half would look like or
what the missing half would look like
which gives me a strong prior on human
object shapes and this is particularly
breaking in the structure in the model
architecture training itself eventually
you will only use the top half of the
model you don't need any of the
adversary losses and shape completion
models these are only what you would
call regularizers to make sure that the
model can indeed learn the right thing
and this this actually helped to a point
where we got 100x Improvement it was
surprising uh actually uh it doesn't
solve the problem it's just that the
errors here are so large that this looks
minusculed by by comparison but that's
still let's say 50 units uh and this is
a unitless number 50 units for let's say
an object of size 100.
right so it's not perfect but
qualitatively these results look much
better than both uh let's say other
methods of doing learning based assembly
which are not using structured priors of
completing objects so that objects look
complete
so that was actually very promising
because I thought this is such a cool
thing to work on so so we did fracturing
in two objects we said why stop it too
uh uh we can break them in arbitrary
number of objects right uh so we went
back to large data sets and we just
published a paper at nurips this year uh
well now we can essentially
algorithmically break objects based on
stresses in in arbitrary number of parts
and you have to Define how many parts
you want and it will break them up
sometimes in chips if you wanted to if
you want to shatter the statue you can
shatter it in hundred parts if you want
and then you can construct a data set
where you can take an arbitrary object
and you say I want the shattered version
of this crew in three parts
now assemble this notice this is a
geometric assembly task the problem
still is very similar
but this time around uh it turns out
that because you have much smaller parts
the current models we have are not very
good at imagining what
the full part of the object would be if
I give you just the chip of the head
it's not clear what the body would look
like
and and that makes this problem very
hard in fact we tried all of our methods
our own method didn't work very well
because this regularization works for
large Parts not very small parts this is
why we actually decided to put it in
benchmarks this is an open invitation
for people we believe this is a problem
that we should be solving our current
methods are not doing very well but this
is a problem uh that is very important
according to me uh this has applications
not just in robotics where you are
trying to build objects but think
archeology where you you only discover
parts of things you never discover a
full dinosaur uh or or in graphics of
course so so independent of this this I
believe is a core ability that somehow
we are born with the ability to complete
things when even the parts have no
semantic meaning
so this is like let's say lesson number
one that we need core or what you would
call fundamental models of these
abilities like geometric mating so that
we can go from there to doing structured
tasks like assembly when you're given
parts and you can do this
okay
let's look at a different problem this
time around you are given objects and
you want to use objects
so let's say you are a hammer and the
task is to sweep the object you're not
allowed to touch the water bottle that's
a constraint and then in the other case
you actually have to apply some sort of
impulse to do the which is the usual
thing
now you can take in a known object where
you don't know the shape or an unknown
instance and the obvious use case can be
okay optimized for grasp and then and
then we will figure out what task we
should do it turns out that that was not
a very good idea because optimal grass
may not result in well anything because
if you grasp the Hammer by the center of
mass it's actually completely useless as
I have uh so so you have to figure out
what is the functional affordance which
may not be optimal for a stage of the
task in fact you grab them independently
so so this is a project that we worked
on a few years ago where you can predict
many grasps you can rank these graphs
based on the current task you are
interested in and you can then pick the
grasp and actually try to do simulation
or actually try it out in the real world
uh whether it will work and that gives
you the signal for learning multiple
tasks this again is a prior of what I
would call functional affordance rather
than labeled affordance a human is not
telling a robot that grabbed the hammer
here because the human has five fingers
while the robot has two so how it needs
to grab and Hammer may look very
different actually we found in this case
hammering like this
is much more stable
than actually trying to do this because
then the row the hammer doesn't slip out
of a paddle geography
so this is again yet important thing to
understand here the lesson here is
affordance
is a property not just of the
environment but property of an
environment with the agent morphology
matters
so I think we were able to show good
results no surprise of course uh we were
able to show better results than
baselines and I'll skip the time to keep
you to give you like the big picture
idea the interesting thing was that the
fact that we were learning these
functional affordances purely from data
allowed us to generalize better to new
objects
and because we used a particular
architecture where we were only using
Point clouds at the time we could also
generalize to a real robot and we could
try the same tasks with real robots
without knowing object models for these
individual parts
and again that we were able to do
multiple tasks in this case both
sweeping and and
uh
so so that's that's good story right so
now
now what we have covered I talked about
first of all having geometric Primitives
of objects we talked about this idea of
can we use objects now let's go one more
level up okay there is a world with
multiple objects can I do some sort of
reasoning let's look at a very simple
problem first let's say the world is
very simple it is marked with some tiles
you need to move that Coke can
to this yellow Square the constraint is
that the curve can never leave that
marked gray tiles so it never goes on
wood right the solution is rather simple
actually uh any motion that I should be
able to do this this is super simple
now you add other objects and suddenly
the problem becomes difficult for motion
planners because now you have to do
discrete decision making can you push
the can directly through it are you
going to push this other object along
with it should you make a discrete
decision of pushing this other object
out of the way first
and that idea of making discrete and
continuous decision makes this problem
suddenly very hard and notice this is
super simple thought example the world
is much more complicated in 3D but this
this happens all the time think of like
loading and unloading a dishwasher you
need to unload clean stuff before you
load dirty stuff right so you are doing
discrete and continuous reasoning
simultaneously
it's not clear how we should do this
right so in this case the answer was yes
you should push it out and then you can
do this
so what we did was we said maybe we can
learn models of dynamics that allow us
to do this simultaneous discrete and
continuous reasoning at the same time
so that I don't have to separate this
reasoning problem from the motion
planning problem completely
independently
in this case what we can do is we can
basically learn a model and I'm I'm not
going into the details as I said but the
main takeaway is is a hierarchical
latent variable model where the latent
variables can be thought of as high
level abstract actions which allow you
to do discrete reasoning if I push this
this will be out of the way I don't need
to worry about what exact position where
it will be
uh so then you can basically do look
ahead-based planning where think of each
of these things as discrete trees while
a single tree can have uncertainty and
and continuity and this allows us to
again go to a real robot and the problem
we show here is very similar that you
have to put the jello box in the Yellow
Block and there are multiple objects in
the way but in this case we are not
doing you know I want to impress upon
this explicit task planning there is
this is an end-to-end control so the
ability to do discrete planning or
decision making is important because
earlier this was done with explicit
search
we are using an object oriented model
here
okay so so we we showed you that you can
use objects you can build these models
if you can detect objects because you
have to understand the objects exist
let's look at the more fundamental
problem in
vision
what are objects
if you look at a scene should you
segment everything ahead of time and
then decide what objects you want to use
let's answer a simple question if you
are an autonomous car
does it matter that the cafe on the side
of the Walk has a handle or not
for autonomous car I would argue it
doesn't matter why would a car have a
representation for a hand there is no
action space that allows it to interact
right so even representation of things
that you see are actually built on
things that you can do if you cannot do
anything about it you actually don't
even observe those things right
how do we build such models that can do
ground depth perception that is Task
away
so in first case we said let's try to
build causal models causal models would
allow us to build uh representations of
the world that is minimal by Design
so let's play this game
I'll tell you the answer for this one it
is basically guess the Dynamics right so
one ball bouncing in a box
uh
try this one
is actually not the trick question it's
just multiple balls in the Box
how about this one
notice that the balls change direction
without Collision sometimes
this is important we need to build
models where there are underlying
connections think of it like this that
when people guessed the fact that there
is gravity they don't actually see
gravity they build models of it by
observing motions
so in this case the model is actually
that one where I have put random Springs
and rods and strings but you don't see
them you only see the balls moving
around now you might say oh but I can
get enough data and I'll just like
memorize this with a new network well
what if I just change that adjacency
Matrix I can have an arbitrary adjusting
symmetics I can have an arbitrary spring
so you need to be able to learn to do
this with very little data that's where
causality comes in we cannot memorize we
need to be able to generalize this and
if you still don't trust me
well then there are objects which don't
have very simple discrete nature there
is a shirt that you need to fold
I don't want to simulate the whole thing
I want to look at only let's say A
reduced order model if you think you
have seen enough shirts then maybe what
about pants
or pant suits and if you still don't
trust me
what about women stops
they are asymmetric and I don't even
know how they are stored actually to be
practical if at all they are ever folded
so Jokes Aside what we did was we
started with visual observations and we
built this model uh where we can start
with object oriented models so we can
Define objects with key points a
sufficient number of key points to
define the object this is learned in an
unsurprised setting
then you can use this key Point model to
think of this as a graph where you need
to Define edges and you need to learn
edges which edges exist and what
parameters do those edges have and then
you can use this graph to actually
predict Dynamics the important thing to
note is along this process the only loss
you get is actually prediction of
Dynamics nothing else because there is
no ground Truth For What the key points
are there is no ground Truth For What
the edges are
so we are only doing prediction noises
and this allows us to actually model
fairly generic things right we started
with the ball example but now you can
actually apply the same model where
ground truth is not even clear for
example what is a 10 point reduce model
for let's say a towel uh or or a shirt
for that matter
right and you can build fairly general
purpose Dynamics models with with these
kind of systems with the same
representation the key is that I am not
training separate models for separate
data sets it's the same representation
trained on all of these data sets
simultaneously so you're basically again
building an object oriented
representation that is sufficient or
minimal for you
it is not doing the whole thing maybe if
the task was to actually model the whole
finite element the number of key points
required would be much larger
right
okay so the takeaway was you can do
interesting causal Dynamics if the
representation is object oriented key
points okay
let's make the problem slightly more
interesting
so people have attempted this idea
actually this idea of key point-based
Dynamics uh over a variety of these
problems so this is I think work from
bataglia at all where they looked at
interaction based Dynamics
if you are in a multi-body system
how do you know what objects matter even
to begin with right what what is
foreground in background uh is the
things that move their programmed or
everything that is a separate texture
that is foreground how do you define
that
so we started with uh even more sort of
like structured model where we which is
called slots not our invention the whole
idea is
you instead of defining the notion of
objects you define what is called a slot
think of a slot as a container for
information
right and we basically argue that
different slots should have different
information that compose the scene so
I'm con I'm basically taking a
continuous representation of the world
and converting it into
discretized abstractions which will help
me do reasoning in the future which is
very useful actually as a tool
and then oops
I can basically just do this frame by
frame where I can learn
different so I can learn that this red
object is actually separate entity than
this purple object I don't want to call
it an object
I could basically so these containers
can contain what whatever information
you want right this is background this
is purple object this is blue object I
could have chosen to use containers for
shape and color separately
but this is again not specified by human
but only reconstruction mass now the
question that we were studying was can
we use this idea to actually build
Dynamics models so that we can do
general purpose tasks more than one
tasks
so that is what we we end up doing we
start with images and we built a slot
encoder to learn these object containers
or slots
now you can take these slots as ordered
sets essentially and you don't need to
worry about what goes in what slot or
what is the actual ordering
we basically learn an attention-based
model which is a Transformer many of you
may be aware uh we are not going to get
into details of it so don't worry about
it if you don't know you're basically
building an attention over these tokens
if you will to predict the next token
what would be the next token with
certain properties in this case you can
really think that
this object has four tokens because
there are four objects uh and then we
are interested in let's say some
properties of these tokens as they
evolve over time
and then you can build an auto
regressive model essentially to predict
future
and because this is this is an encoder
decoder model you can take the predicted
tokens predict the image out of it
reconstruct the image and use
essentially videos
for supervision so the whole process is
what you would call self-supervised you
only need a video to train this model No
Labels explicitly are required so it's
completely unsupervised
uh in that sense it's actually nice
because I can now take in data without
human intervention
so we first started looking at okay
let's try to take this problem and see
if we are actually able to do a good job
of doing Dynamics prediction that was
the problem to begin with
uh and we found that there are a variety
of ways to do prediction in even within
let's say the Deep learning era where
you can use our net based models this is
a simple RNN on top of slots uh
I think swm and vpu farmer uh
I think I'm missing on the details and
then the hours is our slot former model
the important thing here is we are now
able to build a model
that keeps
visual sharpness as it predicts
because you're predicting only tokens
reconstruction is always Sharp
but it also maintains semantic
consistency so for example if you notice
when objects move
they don't disappear
right because again the information
about every object is in a slot so you
can keep consistency
so this essentially allows us to
actually do very interesting stuff now I
can do prediction so I can ask questions
about this world
so we take this one one step forward we
did not intend for this model to solve
this problem it just so happens that
because we can build good Dynamics
models we can ask questions like the
cube and the blue sphere will they
Collide in the in the question so in
doing so you have to build a model that
will actually anticipate a few
collisions in the future
right and again if you show a few
observed States and then make the model
predict the future we found that our
unsupervised model which is in pink here
is actually matching or beating models
which use explicit information about
what objects are and where are they in
the scene which is remarkable because
again we are not building our model to
solve this task
uh
qualitatively
as I said if you notice in both of these
examples
you are predicting through two
collisions this green object collides
with the red object first then reflects
collides with the magenta object and
only then can you answer this question
uh and and
in this case I do want to mention it's
not magic it is a deterministic model so
we are not capturing the stochasticity
of physics that's something that we
could look into we have not so far
we said why stop there can we actually
do decision making with this model now
on more interesting complex what people
call uh let's say puzzle style games so
the game is very simple here
you are allowed to put this red block
anywhere in the scene and then physics
rolls forward
and then the objective is such that
given the construction of the scene
this object the green object should
touch the blue object always and then
this this is one of those sort of like
iPad or or these mobile games where the
construction of the scene can be
arbitrary some objects are stationary
the gray objects uh some objects move
and now you actually have to build a
model that will actually do reasonably
good Dynamics but because it's not just
balls this time around because there are
objects with properties and stuff
and we found that our model was
surprisingly successful first of all we
were able to learn very meaningful slots
for example all the slats were separate
objects
the ball in the cup is one object
because they never separate at least in
this particular environment if they were
to separate they would become separate
objects and then you can roll this out
and using just a rollout model you can
do look at based planning I can
basically do batch decisions over
thousands of possible decisions and then
come up with this model and we were able
to get actually about 80 85 percent
success rate in this game completely
unsupervised
so yet again the takeaway here is
unsupervised but structured models in
this case the structure is object slots
which allow us to do prediction
can build general purpose systems which
allow us to do multiple tasks
okay
so we we looked at perception so far now
let's talk about decision making I
believe I have about 15 minutes
a lot of the recent work in Vision
language has been built on successes of
carefully crafted architectures we did
not start with very simple sort of
connections and just throw data at them
we started with cnns which captured
locality these days a lot of the success
in many of the domains is actually due
to the fact that we can use attention
whether it's cross attention or
self-attention in Transformers that we
can use
there are particular kinds of loss
structures that we use and and there are
particular kind of let's say contrasting
methods that we use
let's look at a problem of robot
decision making many of you may already
be aware of the standard Markov decision
process I will not belabor that
for a case of Robotics you can really
think of it like this that there is an
observation there is some sort of agent
the agent is learned or not it doesn't
really matter the agent has some sort of
update through
that it uses and as it interacts with
the environment the environment provides
it a next state and reward that's
sufficient to understand
this particular mechanism has indeed
fairly gone far we have been able to do
many interesting tasks some from Vision
without knowing structure but often if
you notice they're very what you would
call Specialized task I I have this
domain I will train on this domain and
be able to solve this to me at this
point in fact one could even argue with
sufficient amount of engineering you can
automate any task
but well we were able to do that already
weren't we
so uh so what the question is how do we
do learning fast
babies are born or in in general
organisms are born without full control
of their body in this case I really like
the elephant clip where the elephant
baby is born without having any control
over the trunk but it learns to use the
trunk fairly effectively very quickly
and then on the bottom is a baby playing
in an open-ended environment and it
basically just explores a task space
where there is no well reward function
if you will
so then the question really we are
asking is what sort of
model bias or structured bias do we have
in this Learning System that is enabling
this General generality
to do this I think we have to dive
deeper we have to dive deeper of like
what this decision making looks like we
have an observation that is processed
first of all into some State this can be
your perception system when you think of
an agent we have to look deeper what are
the things that are inside an agent the
obvious thing is there is some sort of
reactive policy but there are a few
other things a transition model maybe
the maybe the agent is thinking about
what needs to be it needs to predict
maybe it has a value function which
allows us to do long-term decision
making and depending on how you use
these things it's either planning or
learning and you have some sort of
update rule and finally even the action
you output actually is transformed into
some control uh uh in some manner
and the questions here are where are the
insights here
one way to solve this mdp problem is
called off policy reinforcement learning
in that setting you basically interact
with the environment collect data
use using that fixed data set you
estimate a value function
I'm not going to Define how we do all of
that detail but then given a value
function you can back out a policy by
doing some greedy search on the policy
and then now you go back and collect a
bit more data and you do this it's
called off policy
because the data that is being collected
and then the queue function that you're
learning are not necessarily from the
same policy that's already
so where is information here first
simple question is if we are asking to
do deep learning uh does the choice of
architecture matter
well why wouldn't it it has mattered in
vision and language we did some simple
testing instead of using MLPs which is
the default currently if you use the
resonates which is basically giving
hierarchical information
we found
even with such a simple trick we were
able to improve performance across the
board on on tasks on on all tasks on
multiple libraries to a point where we
didn't believe that this could be okay
we never wrote a paper about this we
actually wrote like a two-pager and
submitted this to a workshop because we
thought that who would believe this is a
paper
then the question is we have always been
very fascinated with this idea of value
function but when we think of this value
function we are what are we solving we
are basically saying
what is the value of taking one action
in current state
if I follow this policy to the end of
time let's answer a simple question
if I give you a take-home exam
and it has hard questions
it doesn't really matter what order you
do them in
but if I give you the same exam but you
have 30 minutes to do it does the order
matter
probably you will do easy questions
first best bank why not
we are not doing that because we are
solving the same other problem for the
End of Time Time matters so we actually
changed that we showed that if you do
value function which is what we call
Horizon aware
then you are basically giving the policy
and ability to capture different
solution modes in the same policy and
this somehow makes the whole process
again more efficient
going back to our diagram of RL I'm
going to now show you that there's so
much structure to be left on the table
let's look at transition models I
already showed you that you can learn
structure transition models with latent
variable models and you can do planning
with them cool
when we learn transition models or when
we do model based RL or any sort of
model based system often what we do is
we collect some data we fit a predictive
model and the only argument is
prediction is a sufficient objective for
decision making
again I ask I like asking questions can
you predict what is the airflow here
or if you are collected sufficient data
in principle you can
should you
likely no why well it doesn't matter to
the kind of task you need to do there's
almost no task that requires you to
think about airflow next to my hand
so why are we forcing models to learn
things that are existent in the data
so we found exactly that that objectives
in model learning should be task aware
and this appears explicitly when model
capacity is constrained currently we
have been looking at simple problems and
throwing a bazooka of compute so we
never really encountered the problem if
you really constrain the model you start
to see this problem if I have two
dimensional system and I add 100
dimensions of let's say random obstacle
States the model will really get
confused
but you can figure out that only two of
them matter
so this is one example that objective
even even simple things that we take for
granted are not really actually simple
similarly let's look at prediction for
perception
so we have shown in the past that state
representations matter a lot in this
particular case the task was fairly
simple you need to do
Peg insertion but this time around we
learned the representation of the peg
jointly from tactile information and
vision directly on the real robot no no
simulation involved in about three hours
of data this was joint work with
Jeanette and Michelle and Yuka here at
Stanford while I was here but we found
once you learn these representations
RL becomes super easy learning policies
is actually much easier if you have the
right representations
if I flip the question what about
control
well same problem we found that there
are better representations of output
space because essentially
if you can do optimization in some nicer
space then why wouldn't you a very good
example was
manipulation when you are doing
manipulation we found that end effector
control with forces was very good so we
basically came up with again a very
simple idea in hindsight you control the
impedance of contact in the controller
and you operate in that space that is
your policy space policy controls that
and then you can basically go strain in
Sim with vision go to real without well
the magic of domain randomization
so it was very interesting I think it
was extended by Josiah where they
learned learned operational space
control but the idea Remains the Same
and the fact that this was General it
actually works on other morphologies so
we did the same trick where now we are
learning only in centroidal space of uh
of a quadruped and then once the policy
learns this in quite a bit motion we can
basically just apply or wrap it in MPC
to come up with the legs and again
transfer works
so if there's like one thing that you
take away from here please let it be
this that
when you do decision making algorithms
do not take the algorithm for face value
it's not necessary for use to for you to
use any of the things I talked about
but hopefully the lesson is there is a
lot of value that is on there on the
table uh do not leave it on the table it
is existent in all aspects of machine
learning models so it's not just
take machine learning and apply to
robotics there's a lot of interesting
stuff we can we need to do there
so far I talked about simple skills
these are just single skills like
grasping picking
the kind of things we really want to do
require much more effort
we need to do complex things that may
not be discovered you don't discover by
accident how to make pasta you actually
learn to make pasta by watching people
there's not enough eggs in the world to
make a good omelet by Discovery
in fact it has been shown that people
actually learn from imitation it is
important for our cultural transmission
of knowledge without imitation it just
wouldn't work
people have argued in fact half of
YouTube is just how-to videos and so is
Tick Tock I think the world is moving
fast
so so we need to be able to learn uh in
this kind of setup
from well imitation so one of the first
projects we worked on was well can we
collect data for robotics
we have about five minutes and I'll give
you the key Crux of it
we collected a bunch of data we we spent
a lot of time collecting data actually
and I'm not telling you a success story
I'm telling you a failure of something
that we learned a lot from me Ajay and a
bunch of people here collected a lot of
data we are very proud of the
infrastructure we built it allowed us to
collect data from from a bunch of places
we were able to collect a lot of data
and we showed that we can learn purely
from fixed data a reasonable amount of
policy you can even do learning from
vision and again this work was extended
I think that number that I had at 40 is
now I believe 70 or 80. but it is it is
good that you can get to 80 of the books
but it was really living a lot on the
table what was it leaving on the table
if I want to do a task let's say a mom
is teaching a baby
how to sweep
this is what we were doing right now we
had a lot of data of moms showing
sweeping and our robot attempting to do
sweeping most of the times nurse weeping
was happening
the robot basically is just swaying
things that look meaningful
what you really need is the ability to
understand what is happening in the task
and then actually plan for it and
ideally what I call understand the
notion of what is the purpose
of the task and come up with different
plans for it
and this I think is the most exciting
part of the talk
what we really need is what I would call
causal generative models
if you see an object or a scene and you
say open the door you need to understand
not how to open the door but what does
the concept of opening a door means you
need to be able to predict what an Open
Door would look like and this is like
what I would call the ability to apply
abstract actions in the world we have
this internal model and this is what we
can call knowledge
and again I don't claim this idea at all
actually if you look at cognitive and
developmental Neuroscience literature it
seems that they've solved all of
Robotics problems we just need to look
carefully they explicitly say the what
and the how are actually separable
uh the what is what we actually build as
pliers the how is you solve online and
we can do exactly the same
I can figure out what the notion of
abstract actions in in my imagination
and then given that the fact that I know
what an open dishwasher looks like I can
complete the task with online planning
and I'm going to show you that we can
actually do just that
so
you remember that we were using slot
attention for building Dynamics models I
can do even fancy Dynamics models I'll
skip through this slide in the interest
of time for details we can now build a
Dynamics model with a fixed data set
both in simulated and real settings
where I can give it information about
like take jug open fridge put jug in
fridge so and I can basically predict
this system with a single first frame
figuring out like if I take jug in open
fridge the fridge needs to be actually
opened and jug needs to be in the fridge
but because this is a model that I've
learned I can do counter factual I can
start with things that are not in the
data I can take Kettle instead open oven
instead and the same thing I can do for
a real robot data set as well
again because I'm using slots idea the
whole system is semantically consistent
when I move objects Mass transfer
happens
and and just in the context this work
was done last year the world of image
prediction is moving so fast it's really
hard to keep up this came up like two
two days ago I believe or at least I
came across it yesterday so I added this
slide last night
point is it's not that how we ended up
doing it is what you should do the point
is that you need conditional generative
models to do this thing
once you have this model you can now
take this as a goal specification and
attempt this task for example if I want
to open a dishwasher I need to
understand object-centric understanding
of what's opening a dishwasher means
once I have that
all I need to do is an agent-centric
planner it's a goal condition planner
you can do optimal control you can do RL
favorite tool of your choice doesn't
really matter in this case we actually
do optimal control
every sensing here is on board there is
no magic sensing we do not know any of
the 3D models of this thing all we
provide is the information of where to
grasp because in this pipeline we did
not learn to grasp
but the fact that we are predicting that
opened dishwasher looks like this that's
all you need the ability to separate the
what and how really makes all the
difference learning is required on the
what part much more than the how part
this is not a learned behavior yet it is
reactive it is full whole body control
classical robotics all the way
what the argument is lot of learning
needs to happen on the what part and
that is where large-scale pre-trained
models or Foundation models are Stanford
calls it would be very useful
so we talked about this
this is the last slide I want to say
there are multiple things we talked
about but I hope that one thing that I
have impressed upon is there is no
concept of generalization without
structure
the structure in robotics or embodied
decision making is probably markedly
different from what we are using in
vision and language so a plus b is
probably not going to work it will give
you immediate gains and a lot of
dopamine hits but you will probably need
in the long term thinking about what
sort of structure we need for decision
making
and we need to figure out this idea of
learning functional structure from data
we cannot
basically keep the data driven part out
of this
with that I do want to take a step back
and say there are a lot of things that
are the group does including including
Discovery and causality
and safety
a lot of the work that I talked about
today as Mark did mention I've been very
fortunate to collaborate with many
talented far more talented individuals
than I am at different institutions a
lot of this work was completely due to
them I just take credit for making the
talk
and thank you all for being such a
patience and wonderful audience and
thank you again for inviting me happy to
take questions
[Applause]
foreign
we'll take one or two here and then I
think we'll go on to the patio for more
questions
yeah really great presentation uh my
question is about future prediction for
Dynamics models that are more
complicated maybe with more sarcastic
kind of Dynamics how do you envision the
right representation
to make sure that you can have the right
kind of prediction at the right level
like for instance when you drop a bottle
you don't want to predict every single
piece but still get the right idea that
it's broken yes
I think it's much more about the
representation than the Dynamics the
fact that the bottle is broken or not is
a semantic variable not uh not let's say
usually let's say a state or a variable
of the bottle you have to add it on as a
property and then you keep track of it
through some characteristics what set of
semantic variables do we need to keep
probably depends on what tasks you need
to talk so this goes back again that you
need to define a distribution of tasks
that would allow you to choose the right
representation and then we can figure
out what Dynamics models to build I
believe we have a lot of technology to
build the Dynamics fairly well but the
representation problem is completely
open